On Friday, June 28th 2019, it was announced
that the European Commission had reached an
agreement with Mercosur to create the largest
Free Trade Agreement in its history.
It has taken 20 long years to reach an agreement
that affects a population of almost 800 million
people and a quarter of the world's GDP.
Now, Mercosur, one of the most protectionist
and closed economic blocs in the world has
a
huge opportunity to make the economies of
its member countries prosper: the EU is a
colossus
that
buys more
than two trillion dollars from the rest of
the world every year.
Dollars
it spends on all kinds of products.
Brazil, Argentina, Uruguay and Paraguay
now
have before them
the best opportunity they’ve had in
decades
to overcome their economic problems.
There’s only
one condition: they will have to compete.